hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
you may remember me from such videos as
six divided by two parentheses one plus
two
or nine minus three divided by one third
plus one
the first video has over nine million
views and the next video has over seven
million views
right now the internet is going crazy
over another problem
so it's time for the order of operations
to save the day
the problem is sixty divided by five
parentheses seven minus five
what is this equal to
we'll solve this using the order of
operations
this is commonly referred to as pemdas
or bodmus
it refers to the precedence of
operations
we first have parentheses brackets then
exponents orders then multiplication
division and finally addition
subtraction
if you have multiple operations of the
same precedence you should evaluate them
from left to right
so in this expression we have some
parentheses
so we should evaluate 7 minus 5 first
this is a non-controversial part of the
question
and this is equal to 2.
the argument is about what to do next
according to the order of operations
we should evaluate multiplication and
division with equal precedence going
from left to right
therefore we should evaluate
60 divided by 5 first
this will be equal to 12.
finally
we evaluate 12 times 2
and that gives us the correct answer of
24
this is without a doubt the correct
answer according to the modern
interpretation of the order of
operations
but let's time travel for a bit
well historically this division symbol
had a special meaning when you wrote it
in text
so let me go over this interpretation we
would still evaluate the parentheses
first 7 minus 5 is equal to 2.
the question is what to do next
the special rule about this division
symbol is that you would evaluate
everything on the left and divide it by
everything on the right
so if you have x divided by 2y
that would be equal to x divided by
parentheses 2 times y
so if we use this special rule
we would then need to take 60 and divide
it by 5 times 2.
so we take 60 on the left 5 times 2 on
the right and we would form a fraction
as follows
we then would evaluate 5 times 2 as
being equal to 10
and then we would take
60 divided by 10 and get to the answer
of 6.
this is one way that people do interpret
this question
so some people say the answer 6 other
people say it's 24.
so some people would argue the
expression is ambiguously written so
there is no correct answer it is
analogous to a poorly written sentence
for example take the sentence i saw the
man with binoculars
does that mean you used binoculars to
see the man
or does it mean you see a person a man
who had binoculars in his possession
it's an ambiguous sentence and you could
say there's no correct way to interpret
this sentence
there is a point to be made here just as
we should write precise sentences we
should write precise mathematical
expressions
however in practice we have to resolve
ambiguity
just as courts interpret and make
rulings on ambiguous laws
calculators parse and evaluate seemingly
ambiguous expressions like 60 divided by
5 parentheses 7 minus 5.
a calculator will not tell you
oh the expression is ambiguously written
there is no correct answer it actually
will evaluate this expression
so what do calculators do
how do they evaluate 60 divided by 5
parentheses 7 minus 5.
the calculator will interpret it using
its programmed order of operations
its own precedence of how to evaluate
different operators
one way to visualize the process is a
binary expression tree
so imagine you put this into a
calculator
it's going to make a guess
about how to interpret this
and one way a calculator will interpret
this is just as i explained using pemdas
by putting a parentheses between the 60
and the 5.
we can then visualize the binary
expression tree as follows
we have the operation of 60 divided by 5
that's one subtree
we then have 7 minus 5 that's another
subtree
and finally we take these two
evaluations and we multiply them
together
and if you do that you get to the answer
of 24 which is what pemdas or bodmas
says the answer should be
the other people would say
that you should put a parenthesis over
here
after the division sign
the binary tree for this expression will
look different
at the very bottom we have seven minus
five
we then take five multiplied by this
result we then take 60 and divide it by
this result
so we have a completely different binary
expression tree
this binary expression tree will
evaluate to six
so this is what the debate is about is
the answer 24 or is it 6
which binary expression tree do you
think is correct for the above
expression
well we can actually try this on several
calculators
let's put it into google for example
60 divided by five parentheses seven
minus five
how does google interpret this
well if we input this as a search we get
the google calculator result
of 24
and if you zoom in and look at this
expression you'll see it parses it
exactly as the binary tree on the left
we do 60 divided by 5 and then we
multiply it by the quantity 7 minus 5
and that's what gets us to the answer of
24.
google is not the only calculator
that'll do this many calculators in fact
will give you the answer of 24.
one such calculator is the android
calculator app if you put in 60 divided
by 5 parentheses 7 minus 5 you'll also
get the answer 24.
i've also tried this on many many other
calculators you'll also get the answer
24 but i wouldn't be surprised if some
calculator did give the answer 6 if it
evaluated it according to the other
binary tree
but from what i've seen almost every
calculator gives the answer 24.
so in summary 24 is the unambiguous
answer according to the modern
interpretation of pemdas or bodmas and
many calculators also evaluate the
expression this way so i would say 24 is
the correct answer to this expression
i love that people are passionate about
mathematics
and this seemingly simple trivial
problem actually led us to understanding
the order of operations it led us to a
little bit of math history and
typesetting and we got to explore binary
expression trees it's just amazing and
i'm sure the people who are arguing
about this problem will make great
contributions to mathematics and society
because they have such passion about
these seemingly trivial expressions
thanks for watching this video
these math videos which can be watch for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can map the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos
and if you so choose you can check out
my books which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support